انتهت مرحله الصمت اذا في عمليات الانقاذ
فقد الدفاع المدني اماله في العثور على
ناجينا تحت الانقاب وتحت اكوام الركام
الكبيره هنا وفي مناطق اخرى شمال غربي
سوريا لكن تبقى فرق الدفاع المدني تواصل
عملها في انتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاض ومن
تحت الركام خصوصا هنا في جنديرس بيري في
حلب الشمالي جنديرس في الحقيقه هي من اكثر
المدن دمارا بسبب الزلزال هنالك مبان
واحياء كامله سويت بالارض حسب الدفاع
المدني فان نسبه الدمار في هذه المدينه
بلغت خمسه وثمانين في المئه نحو 60 في
المئه من المباني قد دمرت بشكل كامل ونحو
25 في المئه من المباني متصدعه ايلا الى
السقوط جنديرس هذه المدينه لم تعد صالحه
للسكن الاف من سكانها البالغ عددهم نحو 60
الفا فروا منها الى المخيمات او الى مراكز
الايواء منهم الى الصالات او الى المدارس
او الى المساجد هنالك اخرون ينتظرون في
العراء حجم الكارثه هنا كبير الناس في
حاله من الهلع ومن الخوف فرق الدفاع
المدني تواصل عملها
والكل الان يترقب وصول المساعدات مساعدات
سواء من اجل
عون ومساعده فرق الدفاع المدني في انتشار
الضحايا من تحت من تحت الانقاض او مساعده
وغوث النازحين الذين دمرت منازلهم واصبحوا
في العراء هكذا يبدو المشهد هنا في جنديرس
بريف حلب والصوره مشابهه في العديد من
المناطق في عموم شمال غرب سوريا
عمرو حلبي الجزيره من مدينه جنديرس ريف
حلب